If you're looking for rumors, spoilers, and
leaks about No Time to Die, you've come to
the right place.
Grab your martini and load your Walther PPK,
because here's everything we know so far about
the next 007 film.
Details about No Time to Die have been scarce,
but we do have a very minimal plot description.
Here's how IMDb sums it up:
"Bond has left active service.
His peace is short-lived when his old friend
Felix Leiter from the CIA turns up asking
for help, leading Bond onto the trail of a
mysterious villain armed with dangerous new
technology."
It's generic, but it does give us some hints
about where the plot could be headed.
If this is truly Daniel Craig's final run
as Bond, the "one last job" trope could be
rearing its head.
The movie is expected to arrive in theaters
on April 8, 2020, and it'll be directed Cary
Joji Fukunaga, who's best known for helming
Netflix's Maniac and the first season of True
Detective.
And the writing team consists of Fukunaga,
Neal Purvis, Robert Wade, Scott Z. Burns,
and Phoebe Waller-Bridge.
Like some of the other actors who've played
Bond, Daniel Craig has a complicated relationship
with the character.
He's been praised for his performances, and
the franchise has made him an international
superstar and a very rich man.
However, the grueling pace and workload of
an international film series has taken a toll
on him, both mentally and physically.
Craig is no longer a young man, and he's suffered
injuries from working on the Bond films that
have required surgery.
It also seems that he doesn't necessarily
enjoy playing the role anymore.
In a 2015 interview with Time Out London,
he claimed that he would rather slash his
wrists than play Bond again after Spectre
and that if he did do another Bond movie,
it would only be for the money.
He certainly wasn't lying about that last
part, as he's reportedly bringing in a whopping
$25 million for No Time to Die.
Hopefully that much cash coaxes out his A-game.
There are a lot of elements that contribute
to making an epic Bond film, and one of the
most important is a memorable villain.
Great bad guys can make a not-quite-great
007 flick at least entertaining, or they can
elevate an already good film to legendary
status.
No Time to Die is swinging big with its baddie,
enlisting the services of Rami Malek, fresh
off his Oscar win for Bohemian Rhapsody.
"I will be making sure Mr. Bond does not have
an easy ride of it in this, his 25th outing."
Considering the uncertain fate of Christoph
Waltz's Blofeld at the end of Spectre, there
is some speculation that Malek will take a
turn as Blofeld himself, possibly as a clone
or through some sort of surgical alteration.
That is far from confirmed, though, and it
appears that Waltz himself will also be appearing
in the film, so don't count on Malek playing
the iconic villain just yet.
Christoph Waltz may not be the only former
Bond villain set to return in No Time to Die.
According to Page Six, Grace Jones was booked
for a small role in the film.
As fans of the franchise know, Jones previously
played May Day, bodyguard to Chrisopher Walken's
Max Zorin in A View to a Kill and a formidable
physical challenge for Bond.
But she will most likely not be returning
as May Day, as she was completely obliterated
by an explosion at the end of that film.
Unfortunately, it turns out that Jones was
not on the same page as everyone else on this
seemingly cursed production.
According to The Sun, the actress reportedly
thought she was being offered a bigger role,
and she took the small cameo she was actually
given as a bit of a slight.
So it now appears Jones won't be appearing
in No Time to Die after all.
No Time to Die is poised to offer callbacks
to many Bond films of the past, and one of
the most iconic locations in his vast filmography
will appear at the beginning of the story.
When the film was announced, executive producer
Barbara Broccoli said that it'll begin with
Bond enjoying retirement in Jamaica, which
the team considers the spy's "spiritual home."
1962's Dr. No, 007's very first cinematic
adventure, featured Jamaica prominently, so
it seems fitting that this new film will see
Bond return to the idyllic setting to try
to live out a normal life in retirement.
But we know that that will be interrupted
when his old CIA friend, Felix Leiter, comes
calling to rope him back into the game to
deal with a new threat.
Poor Bond, he just wanted to settle down with
Dr. Swann.
Maybe this is why Craig hates the role so
much: he never gets to have nice things.
Major No Time to Die plot points are still
under pretty tight wraps, beyond the fact
that it begins with James trying to get away
from the spy game in Jamaica.
The Daily Mail has revealed that MI6 has moved
on without him.
The agency has given away the 007 codename
to another spy, played by Lashana Lynch, who's
probably best known as Maria Rambeau in Captain
Marvel.
A source close to the film told The Daily
Mail,
"There is a pivotal scene at the start of
the film where M says 'Come in 007,' and in
walks Lashana who is black, beautiful and
a woman."
Lynch has discussed how excited she is for
the role, partly because she is of Jamaican
descent herself.
"We're able to include them in this British
movie.
I'm able to mesh the two cultures, much like
I grew up doing.
I'm Brititsh and Jamaican at the same time."
The Daily Mail source added that Bond, of
course, tries to seduce the new 007, but fails.
The introduction of this new 007 is being
attributed to one of the writers, Phoebe Waller-Bridge,
whose hiring was specifically requested by
Daniel Craig.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.